I don't know what was like in your
household but I know that when I was
growing up none of this stuff got talked
about yeah I mean would you grow up in a
house where where people talk about this
I mean I didn't grow up like in The
Naked house you know like everybody has
a friend or it's like the family's naked
like really comfortable being naked and
you like accidentally see one of the
parents naked I've never never didn't
know the naked family I didn't have it
there was I didn't but I know what
you're talking about there were families
they're just much more comfortable about
nudity which so we're on the other the
O'Briens were on the other end of the
spectrum yeah we were all born in
business suits you know I was somewhere
in the middle in between I remember my
my family they were pretty open about
talking about stuff but you know it
wasn't like super hippie family or
anything like that but we did have this
this x-rated cookbook those it was like
a gag gift for my parents wedding I
think my friends and I would like take
it into my room and look at it and it
was really like a next way to cook but I
don't know what an x-rated cookbook is
let me explain it to you Connor so for
example you could make a tart that looks
like a breast just use a raspberry as a
nipple that was one of the things in the
cookbook the thing that's that stands
out the most to me though that I can
still picture when I close my eyes is
the meatloaf that looked like well look
at like a huge dick
so this isn't like Thanksgiving food
there anything this isn't this isn't
anything where you're celebrating an
occasion this is just yeah I'm one
problem that I have with it is that it
just doesn't look quite enough like a
dick meat low constant meat loving
you're not alone you think there are
others out there that open a diner like
[Applause]
it's not dick like I'll bring me it I
just imagining the having to slice into
it yeah what end do you start yeah what
end do you start on I don't think a man
would do it I think we'd have to leave
that to mom
what you putting mom into it for
somebody's got to cut the meat low okay
I apologize on behalf of my show you
have to come back you're really fun to
talk to thank you yeah please come back
you're great